[موسيقى]
كنت وقفنا في الجزء الاول عند موضوع
مشاركه
من مشاركه اعضاء من جماعه الاخوان
المسلمين في الكادر القضائي وايضا
مساهمتهم في مساله تطبيق الحدود الشرعيه
القطع او حد الحرابه قطع اليد اليمنى
والقدم اليسرى
هذا بيعطينا اشاره على ان يعني ان دائما
يعني الدعايه لجماعه الاخوان المسلمين بان
منهجهم
متمدن وحضاري
متواكب مع تطورات الزمنيه يعني بما يجوا
انفسهم عن التنظيمات الاخرى مثل تنظيم
القاعده ولا تنظيم داعش يعني انا شاهدت
صور
لهذه المجموعه او هذه الجمعيه اللي هم
نظموا انفسهم في داخل جمعيه ممن طبقت فيهم
الاحكام
صورهم مت وفره يعني من بترت يدهم ومن بترت
اطرافها تم تشويههم واصبحوا عاجزين حتى عن
اداء يعني مهامهم اليوميه او انهم يقوموا
باعاله انفسهم في نفس الوقت انه كان
النظام القضائي نفسه مثل ما تفضلت وذكرت
انه لم يكن في هذه الكفاءات حيث ان كثير
منهم
استقاله ويعني اعتزل القضاء باعتراضا على
موضوع تطبيق قوانين الشريعه الاسلاميه
فكيف تشوف
هالموضوع هذا مشاركه الاخوان المسلمين في
هذا الاطار وكما ذكرت اذا كنت تعني
الاخوان المسلمين السودانيين لما يكون هذا
جزءا من برنامجهم طبعا بالنسبه للسياقه
العام للاسلام السياسي وفض فعلا يطرح
شعارات مثل الاسلام هي هو الحل ولكنه لم
يختبر لم يختبر مثلا في تطبيق القوانين
كيف سينزل الشريعه على واقع دوله معاصره
يعني هل اذا استمر للاخوان المسلمين في
مصر كانوا سيطبقونه الحدود
بالطريقه التي حدثت في عهد النميري
بالنسبه للسودان انا كما ذكرتهم يطرحون
كذلك برنامج اوسع من ذلك بكثير هذا
البرنامج كله تعرض لاخت
ليس فقط في فتره النمر من ناحيه النميري
هو كان طبعا
سياق سياسي بالتمام يعني مثلا انت الى حد
الحراره حد الحراره سياسي
وله وجه جنائي فانت لا تدري كيف على من
سيتلزل هذا الحد العام
جريمه الحرابه لصوص يقومون بعصابات تقتحم
البيوت والبنوك امهم جماعات متمرده مسلحه
ضد الدوله
فكل هذه الاسئله لم تسال انا في زعمي ايضا
ان تيار الاسلام السياسي لم يعرف ما هي
الشريعه التي يريد ان نطبقها ولم يعرف ما
هو الحكم سياقات القران التي ترد فيها
الحكم تشير الى
الاحكام الحكومه التي نسميها في التراث
العربي بالحكومه الحكومه الصادره عن قضاء
ولكن الحكم بمعنى الدوله لا سيما الدوله
المعاصره لم يكن مشمولا
في في
ذلك التصور
النميري كل الذي فعله انه عجل المواجهه
عجل المواجهه بين السياق المعاصر وبين
التراث الاسلامي الذي مطى عليه اكثر من
الف عام فيما يتعلق بهذه المسائل
محبوب اسمح لي حضرتك ذكرت انه الاخوان
المسلمين ما شاركوا في موضوع
يعني في القضاء لم يشاركوا الاخوان
المسلمين في القضاء لكنهم احنا نتكلم عن
الدكتور حسن الترابي هو كان المشرف او
رئيس
اللجنه التي تشرف على هذه القوانين
فحتى ان البعض بيعتبر بان القوانين سبتمبر
1983 هي البرنامج الفكري والعملي لجماعات
الاخوان المسلمين وطبعا السياق شديد الدقه
يعني انا لم اقل ان القضاه لم يشاركوا
مثلا من اشهر القطاعات الذين شاركوا في
محاكم المسلمين الاخوان المسلمين الاستاذ
حافظ الشيخ الذي اشرت اليه قاضي الاستئناف
الشيخ محجوب حاج نور الذي اجاز وفسر حكم
محكمه الموضوع في الاعدام للاستاذ محمود
محمد طه
كانوا من قاعده الحركه الاسلاميه ومعروفين
فيها يعني
لكن
السياق الذي اشرت اليه هو انه
لم يكن هذا هو البرنامج
الذي تسير اليه الحركه الاسلاميه صحيح
طبعا ان هم في الدستور الخاص لجماعه
الاخوان المسلمين
يكتبون ان واحده من اهدافهم هو تطبيق
الشريعه واقامه الحدود
وكانوا يظنون ان هذا الامر سيكون امرا
نظريا
مكتوبا فقط في الاوراق اما ان يطبق سياسي
يعني تقصد انهم يستخدموا هذه كتوظيف سياسي
لكن اذا وصلوا للحكم لن يفعلوها وكانوا
طبعا بالذات في سياق السوداني كان هنالك
حزب الامه وهو حزب ياتي من طائفه الانصار
وهي طائفه مجاهده قبل مئه عام او حزب
الاتحاد الديمقراطي قاعدته تقوم على جماعه
الخ يا جماعه صوفيه من الجماعات التي
ادخلت التصوف في السودان وهو كيف سيتميز
كيف
ستزعم انك تريد ان تقدم للشعب السوداني
شيئا جديدا اسمه الاخوان المسلمين في
الاول كان كما ذكرت كان هنالك اتجاه
لمساله الدستور الاسلامي ثم عندما جاءت
ترابي وكان منتبها لهذه الاشكالات اشار
الى انها الميثاق الاسلامي ان يتوافق
الناس على ان تكون الوجهه العامه للحياه
هي الاسلام في السودان اول اختبار حتى قبل
اختبار النيميري انت اشرت اليه
والدستور 1968 الذي جاءت فيه ملامح
اسلاميه كثيره وهذه الملامح لم تكن رغبه
الحركه الاسلاميه وحدها ولكن رغبه كذلك
حزب الامه مثلا بقياده او زعامه الامام
العادي المهدي كان يريد ان يطبق الشريعه
وكان يعتبرها احد احلامه
الحزب الشيوعي في عام 68 كان بحجه
التعبئه كانت بحجه الرده او مخالفه
الاسلام ثم تولى الاسلاميون في البرلمان
توظيف هذه الهبه الشعبيه ضد الحزب الشيوعي
صوب حادث معين ليجعلوا منه انه حزب مضاد
للديمقراطيه
يطرد اعضاءه من البرلمان ويحرم العمل
السياسي فكان هذا كله مخالف تماما
للسياقات المجتمع السياسي والسياقات
الدوله المعاصره انا في تقديري هذا هو
المازق انه انت تزعم انك تريد ان تعود
بالحياه العامه المعاصره الاسلام ولكنك لا
تستطيع لانه اذا اردت ان تسلم التعليم
والاعلام والقضاء والجنديه هذا يحتاج لجهد
حضاري هذا عمل مجتمع كامل كما حدث في
الحضاره الغربيه الصياغه
ما يسامحني عشان ودي في نقاط كثيره ودي
نغطيها قدر الامكان لو بنيجي للبنود
الاخرى من قوانين سبتمبر قضيه موضوع
الجهاد بان يعني واجب اسلامي وايضا موضوع
الزكاه
والامر بمعروف والنهي عن المنكر ايش تقول
لي عنها كيف تم تفعيلها ولاي مدى كانت
لاغراض سياسيه هذه الامور والجهاد لم يصدر
فيه قانون في ايام النميري ولكن الذي احدث
خلل كبير جدا وممكن اعظم الاثار على
الحاله السودانيه والذي ادى الانفصال
الجنوب فيما بعد هو
محاوله النميري ان يطبق هذه القوانين على
الجميع ثم
محاولته كذلك لخرق اتفاقيه اديس ابابا
وحجه انه وجد عون وزخم جماهير كبير وجدد
روح نظامه هو جدد حياه نظامه وهذا ادى الى
هذه النتيجه
فيما يتعلق بقانون الامر المعروف وانها
المنكر ظل يدور حوله نقاش حتى عهد
عند ذلك عادوا الى الاظابير والانابيش
واعادوا بمساله الحسبه انه من هو المحتسب
ما هي سلطاته فكان كذلك هذا مجال بتاع
تباين وخلل كبير جدا بسنه كم وايش دور
الترابي فيها
الترابي طبعا لم يكن وحده هو
في كثير من الاسلاميين داخل حركه اسلاميه
السودانيه تلقوا تعليما تقليديا مؤمنين
تماما الايمان الى هذه اللحظه بهذه
الافكار وان الشريعه الاسلاميه برقم تطبق
كلها وفورا هذا موجود ومبسوط في اعضاء هذه
الحركه موقف
عن المنكر فيما يتعلق بجهاز الحسبه وايضا
متابعه النساء في السودان هو تحدث
المفارقه في موقف الترابي انه مثلا جمع
وزراء الارشاد سماهم وزراء الارشاد وزير
التربيه والتعليم وزير الرياضه وزير
الشؤون الدينيه وزير الرعايه الاجتماعيه
وكون منهم مجلس حتى هذا المجلس يتولى فعلا
المسائل المتعلقه بارشاد المجتمع واخلاقه
وكذا ولكن عندما يبرز قانون مثل قانون
الحزبه او قانون الامر بالمعروف والناعم
المنكر لا يستطيع ان يعارضه لانه هذا سيضع
في مواجهه الجماعات السلفيه
ومواجهه جماعات حتى من داخل
كانك
لا انا والله
اشرح لك هو للمشاهدين السياق لانه هذا
الموضوع شديد الدقه وليس موضوعا سياسيا
بهذا المعنى هو موضوع فكري وثقافي وسياسي
وتاريخي ومعقد ومتصل
جدا طبعا الابتعاد السياسيه التي سادت
ضد التراب وضد قوانيس التمويل هذه سهله
مبسوطه وموجوده ولكن ان نذهب الى جذر
الموضوع الى اين الاشكال الى اين حدثت
المفارقه في الحركه الاسلاميه الى اين
عجزت عن ان توافق بين شعاراتها وبين
سياقات الدوله المعاصره وهو موضوع شديده
عقيد هو في اطار عندنا اطار فكري ومن اين
تاتي هذه القناعات وما مدى دقتها ومدى
فاعليتها ومدى قابليه اساسا تطبيقها في
الوقت الراهن وفي اطار اخر احنا انا ودي
اني اعرف في المواقف في هاتف بدايتها من
من شخصيات كانت كانت هي تتصدر المشهد وهي
التي يعني يتبعها كل اطياف الحركه
الاسلاميه وكانت تعتبر كنموذج وقياده لهذه
الحركه فعشان كده انا مهم عندي اعرف موقف
الترابي من موضوع الامر بمعروف والنهي عن
المنكر انه كانت وهل كان هناك يعني شخصيات
دينيه اللي تخرج للحسبه للنساء ام كان بيد
رجال الامن وانا اجتهدت معك حتى يعني
ونركز في عالم الاشخاص لكن انا معروف
ركز في الافكار وعالم الافكار
تطور الافكار
وهذا مهم طبعا لانه
اثرت على ليس المحيط الاقليمي فقط ولكن
على كل عالم المسلمين
ومثلا اذا تحدثنا عن تجربه مثل تجربه
الباكستان
وتجربه الموجود الذي
اسلنا هذا المصطلح الذي يسميه
المصطلحات الاربعه في الاسلام ومنها مصطلح
الحكم وانه هو الذي الهم سيدغوت بمساله
متعلقه بانه اخص خصائص الوليه هي الحكم
فهذه كلها مسائل شعارات عبات فعلا هذه
الجماعات ولكنها لم تختبر حتى لم تبحث
البحث الكافي الفكري الكافي هذا هو
الاشكال مع الحركات الاسلاميه المعاصره هي
انها اما ان تذهب الى اخر الطريق
فتصبح مثل داعش لانه هذه النهايه المنطقيه
لمن يؤمن بهذه الافكار او ان تقوم بمراجعه
شامله وحقيقيه وعند ايزي هي ستحول الى
جماعه سياسيه معاصره تستصعب كل هذا التراث
الانساني
فقصه النميري هي قصه محدوده في اعوام يعني
من 83 هو سقط في 85 هذه القصه التي نحكي
فيها مدتها عامين لكن بعد ذلك جاء
الاسلاميون وحكموا ثلاثين عاما
هذه الثلاثين عاما كان ممكن كل شيء متعلق
بانه يتحول هذا المجتمع
الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه كان عندها
شعار اسمه سياقه المجتمع السوداني هذا
الشعار اتيح له ان يقوم بثوره التعليم
ثوره اعلام ان يقوم بالجهاد كما ذكرتي هذه
المقولات اختبرت هل يمكن ان نطبق
الفقه الخراج وفقه الربا على اقتصاد دوله
معاصره هذا كان سؤال كبير جدا واختبار
كبير جدا لتجربه الانقاذ انا هنا بسالك في
موضوع الزكاه
طبعا ننتقل الى مرحله ما بعد
الصادق المهدي
والانقلاب عليه من قبل في العام 88 من قبل
طبعا عمر البشير
ومن قبل عمر البشير وطبعا كان الدكتور حسن
الترابي هو من
في صداره هذه الانقلاب لكنها كان خلف
الاضواء الى ان كشف بعد ذلك هذا الدور
فكان في موضوع
الزكاه وتحريم الربا
وتوظيفه هذه
الاستغناء عن البنوك الربويه وانشاء بنوك
اسلاميه الى اي مدى كانت هذه فعلا حقيقيه
ام انها حيله
لتوفير مصدر مالي للحركه الاسلاميه في ذلك
الوقت وهل كانت هي معفيه بعيده عن الجانب
الربوي او فائدتها كانت اقل ام اكثر ممكن
ناجل هذه الاجابه قليلا لانك ذكرتيني
بموضوع السيد الصادق المهدي
في ندوه ندوه كبيره جدا في جامعه الخرطوم
تحدث عن قوانين سبتمبر واثناء صدورها بعد
وقت قليل جدا من صدورها بانها لا تساوي
الحبر الذي كتبت به ولكن عندما جاءت
الانتفاضه واسقطت النميري كان واحد من اهم
اشعارات الانتفاضه هو الغاء قوانين سبتمبر
لم يستطع الوزير العدل الذي جاءت به
الانتفاض الشعبيه ان يلغي هذه القوانين
لانه كان يعلم ان جزرها الشعبي
سيضعه في مواجهه كبيره جدا وكان يعلم كيف
يمكن للحركه الاسلاميه ان تستغل ذلك
الصادقه المهدي نفسه عندما اصبح رئيس
وزراء لم يستطع ان يلغي هذه القوانين
وشارك مع الحركه الشعبيه في نقاش في منطقه
اسمها
على ذلك ولكن عندما حالف الجبهه الاسلاميه
القوميه واصبحت جزءا من حكمه لا سيما في
المرحله الثانيه من التحالف
قال ينبغي ان نسارع لوضع القانون الجنائي
واجازته وهو القانون الذي يحتوي على
الحدود حتى هذا قبل قانون 91 يعني واحده
من قوانين التي كانت تقوم بها الجمعيه
التاسيسيه ثم جاء اتفاق المرقني وقرن
ونص على هذه الحدود لم يستطع
صيدليه ايوه في البدايه ان يوافق على لا
يعني اذا كما ذكر الدكتور واثق الكبير ان
العلمانيه في الصياغه السوداني هي القاء
قوانيس سبتمبر الذي تطالب به الحركه
الشعبيه هو الغاء قوانين سبتمبر والصدقه
المهدي كان يعتقد انها لا تساوي الحبر
الذي كتبت به ولكنه بدل عن ذلك عندما اصبح
الترابي نائبا عاما ثم وزيرا للخارجيه قال
ينبغي ان قمنا بدراسه عميقه لهذه القوانين
وازلنا الشوائب التي كانت في عهد النميري
واتى بها للبرلمان لاجازتها
فوجئ بانه الشريك في الحكم
السيد المرغني قد ابرم اتفاقا في بغداد مع
دكتور
السلام للسودان عام 88
الصادقه المهدي لم يستطع ان يؤيد هذه
الاتفاقيه التي كانت فعلا ستجلب السلام
للسودان فخرج الحزب الاتحاد الديمقراطي من
حكومه الوفاق التي كانت ثلاثيه بين الجبهه
والصادقه المهدي وحزب الاتحاد او السيده
المرقني فاصبحت ثنائيه بين الجبهه
والصادقه المهدي ثم في مرحله ثالثه
اضطر الصادق المهدي ان يخرج الجبهه لانه
ماذا يرى الجيش نفسه كتب مذكره انه هذه
القوانين تعيق وجود مساعدات
للجيش السوداني حتى يستطيع ان يخوض معاركه
ضد حركه التمرد هذه المذكره قلبت الاوضاع
واخذت المجتمع الدولي اعتراض على تنفيذ
هذه العقوبات نعم نعم
هذه قصه قوانيس سبتمبر هذه قصه ادت الى
نتائج ضخمه في السودان رغم انها بقيه امام
مع النميري ولكنها
الى فصل جنوب السودان ولذلك هي ليست قصه
سهله هي قصه قصه بالغه التعقيد اذا اتيح
لك يوم ان تعقدي حلقه عن مفاوضات
المفاوضات نيفا باشا بين الحركه الشعبيه
لتحرير السودان بقياده
وحزب المؤتمر الوطني الذي يمثل حركه
الاسلاميه بقياده نائب الرئيس السيد علي
عثمان محمد طه كانت قوانيس تكتمل هي عظمه
النزاع ما يسميه البريطانيون
بسبب انهم لم يستطيعوا ان حتى ان
يفرزوا جيب في العاصمه القوميه لكي تكون
عاصمه
تعبر عن كل السودان لم تستطع الجماعه
المفاوضه في نيفاشا ان تقوم بذلك وهذا ادى
طبعا الى الاستفتاء الذي ادى الى فصل
الجنوب هي ليست قصه عابره ولكنها قصه
معقده الاسلام والمعاصره الاسلام
في مفكر ثاني مهم اسمه فضل الرحمن قال ان
السيد الموجود يكتب ويكتب ويتحدث في
العاصمه ويتحدث كثيرا ولكنه يتحدث بسطحيه
بالغه كلما تطرحه الحركات الاسلاميه حول
الشريعه او حول الاسلام و حول صدى المعاصر
هذا الطرح في منتهى السطحيه لا يستطيع
اسمحي ابغى اسالك في موضوع الصادق المهدي
لما بدا بخطوات لمحادثات سلام مع جون
جراند
الترابي
وجبهته كانوا وقفوا ضد هذا الاتفاق لان
احد بنوده بان يعفى الجنوب من تطبيق هذه
الحدود او تجميدها بشكل عام لكن الترابي
والجبهه اعترضوا على هذا لتخريب الاتفاقيه
السلام ثم في 2005 التراب نفسه عقد هذا
الاتفاق مع جون جرينج في
2001 في 2005 الحكومه التي شق عنها
الترابيه التي عقدت هذا الاتفاق ولكن انا
قلت لك ان القصه تبدا باتفاق المرجله
المرغني الذي كان يمكن ان
يحدث فتح فيما يتعلق العلاقه بين الشمال
والجنوب
ثم المرحله التاليه التي اصبح فيها صادق
المهدي رئيس وزراء كان يخاف من المزاودات
التي ستقوم بها الجماعات الاسلاميه ضده
الى قاعده دينيه ناشط لك ان الحركه
الاسلاميه هذا الانقسام في السياسه
السودانيه يعني حتى منتصف الستينات لم تكن
السياسه السودانيه تعاني من انقسام بين
اسلامي وغير اسلامي كان
المحبوب فينا بس نقطه ابغى يعني نوضحها
اكثر يعني الدكتور الترابي في هذا الدور
الصادق المهدي وهو طبعا ترابي هو زوج زوج
لاخت الصادق المهدي
حاول ان يعترض طريقه ومشوار مشواره
بالدعوه الى الالتزام بتطبيق الشريعه حتى
في الجنوب ذات الاغلبيه المسيحيه صحيح نعم
هو طبعا القصه تبدا كما ذكرت لك منذ حل
الحزب الشيوعي الصادق المهدي اذا نظرنا
اليه كمفكر الاسلامي
معاصر هو تقريبا في نفس ايدولوجيا الاسلام
السياسي
ولكنه شديد الانتباه الى تعقيدات الواقعه
المعاصر لذلك يقوم باجتهادات كثيره جدا
ولكنه الان لم يخرج من هذا القفص هو قام
بقفز عاليه ولكنه ضرب سقف القفص لم يستطيع
ان يخرج من هذا القفز
التجديد التحديث الذي دعا اليه
فضل الرحمن لم يبلغوا التراب ولم يبلغوا
صادق المهدي طب عن موقف الترابي في هذا
الله يسلمك استاذ محبوب موقف الترابي انه
عندما يعارض ويقف في وجهها صادق المهدي
تجاه ان يعني تجميد هذه القوانين العقوبات
الشرعيه
وعدم تنفيذها تحديدا في مناطق الجنوب ذات
الاغلبيه المسيحيه كيف تشوف موقف الترابي
هنا هو موقف مشهور
يتفضل هو موقف سياسي بالتمام وليس موقف
اسلامي وهذا مشهور لانه هو قبل ان يعمد
الى انقلاب 89 قام بحشلي في الشوارع كان
محدودا ولكن كل اسلاميين كانوا مخالطين
فيه سماه ثوره المصاحف هي ثوره ضد اتفاقيه
المرغني
في رمضان 89 كان الهدف منها هو مقاومه
تجميد القوانين وفي نفس الوقت تهي اتى
المناخ السياسي للانقلاب
وحجه الانقلاب وان السيد الصادقه المهديه
والسيده المرواني وهذا كان واضح جدا في
خطب الترابي الاخيره قبل الانقلاب ان شيوخ
الدين اصبحوا يسلمون حركه الاسلاميه نفسها
ساهمت مساهمه كبيره في تصوير قرن ليس
كقاعده وطني يبحث عن عن عداله للمهمشين
ولكن كمسيحي وصهيوني وغربي
وانفصالي
فكانت هذه الرؤيه التي تركزها الحركه
الاسلاميه تحفظ لها تميزها
الحركه الشعبيه في الجنوب بالضبط لانه
السرعه السياسيه كلها كانت ماضيه للتكامل
مع قرن واحلال السلام في السودان وهذه
المفارقه هي التي ادت الى الانقلاب مصلحه
الحركه الاسلاميه من هذا الساده المحبوب
مصلحتها هي انها ستعزل نهائيا عن الساحه
السياسيه لان هي كسبت في دوائر خريجين
وكسبت في في بعض الدوارج الجغرافيه واصبحت
قوه ثالثه ولكن اذا تحول الميزان السياسي
اذا تحالف المرغني وجون والصادق المهدي هم
قطعا خارج هذا السياق لانه سيضع فيتو على
حركه سياسيه معاصره تريد ان تطبق عليه
قوانين دينيه
ولا تريد حتى ان تعزل الجنوب فهي كانت
منتبهه الى هذا كل الزخم الذي قامت به
خلال اربعين عام يمكن ان يزول في لحظه وان
تصبح قوه سياسيه هامشيه وان تبدا المعارضه
من جديد ان كل القوى السياسيه كانت لها
علاقات مع الدكتور جون ومع الحركه الشعبيه
ذهبت
في اديس ابابا وذهبت الى كوكادام ثم وقعت
اتفاقيه المرغني قرن في بغداد وكانت
الامور تسير لانه سيحدث
سياق سوداني جديد
سيوقع السلام مع الجنوب ويحل هذا الاشكال
القديم بين منذ ما قبل الاستقلال بين
الشمال والجنوب
هي هي مساله خشيه الترابي من عزل من عزلهم
او تقليل من حضورهم في المشهد السياسي
السوداني كقوه جماهيريه وشعبيه من خلال
هذا التحالف وكذلك وضع برنامجهم الذي اشرت
اليه وهو الشريعه والحدود في مواجهه
المجتمع السياسي السوداني واجتمع الاقليمي
والمجتمع الدولي
المحبوبه حاكيني عن ما بعد ما بعد انقلاب
88 هنا وتولي عمر البشير الحكم في السودان
ومعه دكتور حسن الترابي وحضرتك كنت احد
يعني الفاعلين في هذه المرحله وما بعدها
في المؤتمر الشعبي ايضا
ومساعدا للترابي ودي تحكي لي قانون تطبيق
الشريعه في ذيل فتره الى اي مدى كان استمر
تطبيقها وايضا موضوع الجهاد هو استمر كل
الفتره من عام واحد الزعيم مجرد ما اجازه
المجلس الوطني الانتقالي اصبح قانون نافذا
وساريا نطبق حد السرقه القطع ويطبق الحدود
الاخرى وحتى ان الترابي له اراء مشهوره
جدا يرفض فيها اعتبار الرده حدا او عن
الخروج من الاسلام يعتبر جريمه هو لم
يستطيع ان يقنع المجلس الوطني لانتقالي
برايه
واخبرهم بانه هو خالف
الاجماع الفقهاء في موضوع الرده ولكن
القانون سرى رغم رغما عنه رغما عن رايه
اصدر قديمه جدا
يؤيد ويدعم بكل يعني ما لديه في موضوع
التطبيق الحدود الشرعيه وحد الرده حتى له
حوارات مع الصحافه الغربيه هو اصلا هو هذا
موضوع هو ان يعود بالحياه للاسلام من
ضمنها القوانين هذا برنامج
اولا واخيرا وثانيا وثالثا هذا هو موضوع
حضرتك تقول انه كان هو معارض لموضوع يعني
ضد موضوع حد ضد رغم انه هو
هذه الاخت الكريمه هذا اجتهادات فقهيه
منهم انا اخبرتك في الاول انه فقهيا ايام
النميري قال ان
الخمر ليست حدد يمكن ان يتاح للقاضي ان
اختار اخرى غير الجلد فتعتبر تعذيرا وفقا
للتعريف المعروف للتعزير في
الشريعه الاسلاميه
عنده هذه الاجتهادات ليه مثلا بعض الناس
تنظر للترابي باعتباره مفكر مثلا تقدمي
لانه هو يملك ناصيه الفقه جدا وكان طبعا
التراب كان سيساهم لو فعلا عمد الى تفكيك
الفقه القديم يعني مثلا الزواج المسلمه من
الكتاب هذا هو اقره في 79
في المشهد السياسي في السودان هو اصلا
الموضوع الاسلام السياسي موضوع الحركه
الاسلاميه يواجه تناقض جذري مع بيئه
المجتمع السياسي المعاصر ومع بيئه الدوله
المعاصره هم لم يستطيعوا حتى بهذا المستوى
الفكري الجيد ان يحلوا هذا الاشكال لذلك
يقع في التناقضات التي تشيلين اليها
يرفض امر ثم يعود ويقبلونه يصرون على
القوانين الحدود ثم يجمدونها
هذا هذه هي تحديات الواقعه وهذا كان موضوع
الجهاد
الموضوع الجهاد هو بالطبع كانت الحمله
قويه جدا على نظامه الحمله العسكريه من
العسكريه كانت تقودها اربع دول من المنطقه
اثيوبيه واريتريا ويوقندا وكينيا كلها
كانت تقود حمله عسكريه ضدهم
وكان هو نظام يرفع شعارات الاسلام ويتحدث
عن الاسلام ليلا نهار ويتحدث عن مؤامره
على الاسلام
وانهم سيكونون هم الجزو الحضاريه التي
ستعيد امجاد الاسلام كان هذا الخطاب
اليومي للانقاذ ففي هذا السياق تم تعبئه
الاف الشباب
وتحولت حرب الجنوب بالفعل من حرب
اهليه بين حكومه مركزيه
ومتمردين في بعض الوصف الى حركه جهاد
اسلامي وعندئذ لم تخلص للقوات المسلحه فقط
دخلت اليها ارتال من المواطنين العاديين
المدنيين ما سمي بالدفاع الشعبي ودخل
اليها الاف الطلاب وتحول المشهد بالكامل
لجنوب السودان من انه كانت حتى حتى موضوع
الجهاد تم توظيفه سياسيا يعني توظيف هذا
المصطلح الديني الجهاد والقتال الى اطاره
يعني بصيغه سياسيه يعني اقنعوهم انهم
يقاتلوا كفار ومرتدين في داخل السودان
باستخدام مفرده الجهاد وطبعا لكن الاقناع
ليس فقط انه الجنوبيين كفار ومرتدين ولكن
هنالك مشروع مشروع صهيوني غربي امريكي
صليبي يريد ان يقضي على المشروع الاسلامي
في السودان
فلابد من الجهات دفاعا عن هذا المشروع
فالذي يقوم
مصطلح المعاصر في السياسه يغير المفاهيم
السياسيه المعاصره فعندئذ بتحول الى سياسه
غريبه غير انها تورط الشخص الذي يبداها من
الحركه الاسلاميه تورط البلد في مشاكل
الكبرى اذا كان الوضع ديمقراطي تبرز مذكره
مثل مذكره الجيش احنا في هذه في موضوع
الجهاد في هذا الوقت هو بدا يعني تحفيز
المقاتلين او المؤيدين او الانصار من
الجنسيات العربيه ومنها كانت تنظيم
القاعده في هذه المرحله صحيح هو بالطبع
الاطروحه الحركه الاسلاميه السودانيه
يطرحها عالميه
تريد ان تصدر هذا النموذج وانت استورد
الذين يؤيدون هذا النموذج وهذا اعلن
التراويح في محاضرته في عام 92 في
بريطانيا الجمعيه العلميه البريطانيه انه
هذا مشروع للخلافه الاسلاميه
بمعنى جديد هو مشروع كل المسلمين في كل
العالم
وانه
السياسه الشرعيه الاسلاميه هي سياسه تمتد
لتشمل كل المسلمين في كل العالم هذه واحده
من اصول تفكير الترابي المسلمين ينبغي ان
يتكامل سياسيا حتى يصنعوا مشروع حضاري
كامل
طب استاذي
تطبيق الحدود في لدينا احد من طبق عليه
قانون تطبيق الشريعه نحن بدنا نرجع الى
عهده النميري هو الاستاذ محمود محمد طه
ودي اسالك كيف تشوف موقف الترابي من تطبيق
حد حكم الرده على الاستاذ محمود طه هو
طبعا كان في وظيفه سياسيه رفيعه وكان
مستشار رئيس الجمهوريه فكان في وظيفه
سياسيه رفيعه جدا عندما طبق هذا الحد على
الاستاذ محمود
نعم كان هو مساعد رئيس الجمهوريه تقريبا
كانت الوظيفه الثالثه في الدوله
فلذلك رقمي انه الحركه الاسلاميه كان لها
صحف مستقله عن صحف حكومه النويري لم تعلق
على هذا الحكم لو لم تعيده ولكن بعد فتره
عندما اشتدت الحمله على النميري اضطر ان
يصرح تصريحات تؤيد هذا الحكم بعبارات
صريحه من الذي يقدم اطروحه اسلام سياسي في
واقعنا هذا المعقد
الكثيف
سيواجهات ضخمه سيكون مثلا موقف الترابي
الفقيه هو انه يرفض حد الرده ولكنه الوزير
المسؤول في هذا المنصب الرفيع في حكومه
نيميري مضطر للدفاع الرئيسي
ولذلك حملت تصريحات واضحه جدا للتراث تؤيد
اعدام محمود محمد طه وتصف ان رده محمود
محمد طه من اكبر انواع الرده في التاريخ
الاسلامي رغم انه كان في حاله صمت تام
بالتعليق على جمله الفكره الجمهوري وعلى
جمله النشاط الذي كان يقوم به الاستاذ
محمود والاخوان الجمهورين في السودان لا
يمكن يعلق ولكن الظروف وضعته في هذه
المواجهه حتى
التناقض مستمر منذ حل الحزب الشيوعي عام
68 الى اعدام الاستاذ محمود في عام 85 هذا
التناقض سلسله متصله منذ ان احدث هذا
التفارق في السياسه السودانيه بين السياسه
الوطنيه وسياسه اسلاميه اظل هذا التناقض
ملازم لمواقف الترابي وللمواقف الحركه
الاسلاميه
تسمح لي ليش ربطتها بان الترابي يعني دعما
للنميري في ذلك الوقت وليس انه سعيد بان
يتخلص من منافس مهم في الساحه السودانيه
وفي الحركه الاسلاميه في السودان هو هو لم
يكن يعتقد ان الاستاذ محمود منافس مهم
وكان يعتبرها ظاهره موجوده في كل التاريخ
الاسلامي لان هنالك جماعات اذا قرات كتاب
الملل والنحل ستجد الاف يشبهون الاستاذ
محمود
وحتى الاستاذ الشاعر الكبير صلاح احمد
ابراهيم قال ان الترابي سيجد محمود محمد
طه اذا نظر لابنائه سيجد حاله من ناحيه
الاب حاله من ناحيه الام حاله حمد التراب
الذي ادعى المهديه وحاله الامام المهدي
الذي اشرت الى انه هو صهر الشيخ الترابي
فهذه الظواهر يعتبرها موجوده التاريخ
الاسلامي لا تزول دائما ياتي شخص يدعي
العيسويه او يدعي المهديه وهو الى محمود
محمد طه في هذا الاطار انه لا يشكل خطرا
عليه لا يستطيع ان يقف امام المد الشعبي
الذي هو نجح في اقامته بتعبئه وحشت
الشعر الاسلاميه في هذا الاتجاه ولم يكن
اعتقد انه لم يكن يريد لنيميري ان يعدم
الاستاذ محمود لانه هذا سيضع في مواجهه
العالم سيحمل مسؤوليه في قنا عنها ولكن
كما ذكرت لك ان التناقض سيحدث وان
المسؤوليه ستاتي وان المواجهه لابد ان
تكون قائمه ولم يتم تاصيل هذه المواقف
بصوره واحده
ابغى اسالك الله يسلمك استاذ محبوب في
نقطه البنوك الاسلاميه التي اقرها الترابي
عوضا عن البنوك التي وصفها بالربويه مع ان
هناك راي اخر يقول بان الفائده كانت من
البنوك الاسلاميه اعلى من فائده هذه
البنوك التي وصفت بالربويه فالى اي مدى
كان استغلال هذا الموضوع لضخ يعني ميزانيه
بعد الانقلاب في 88 وللمؤتمر الشعبي
لسلطه التي كانت بيد سنتراب لذلك الوقت
وطبعا المبادره التي بدات في بنك الشعب
بنك فيصل بدات حتى قبل الانقاذ بفتره
طويله على ايام النويري
وساعدت الحركه الاسلاميه على انشاء هذه
البنك واعفاءه من الضرائب لمده طويله
ولكنه لم يقم على فلسفه اقتصاديه
البنك الاسلامي هو تعديل على البنك الربوي
التقليدي الصيغه الاسلاميه هي صيغ لا تقوم
على فلسفه المرابحه
والمزارعه والمساقات كل هذه الصيغه لم تكن
صيغ قائمه على فلسفه اقتصاد متكامل هذه
مجرد حيل كانت لانك انت تريد ان تقول انه
حصل الاسلام لهذا البنك لم تقم فلسفه
للبنك الاسلامي قامت
قامت
جماعات للفتوى
داخل الاسلاميه هذه الجماعات تعرض عليها
المعامله فتقول ان هذه المعامله حلال او
حرام او فيها مخالفه او غير مخالفه
للشريعه الاسلاميه
وهذا بالطبع ادى لانه هذه العمليات تدخل
في تعقيدات كبيره لانه الفقه المتعلق بهذه
المسائل فقه ناقصه الى حد كبير
المصرف المعاصر لا علاقه له بانظمه الريبه
التي كانت سائده في المدينه
فلم لم يسلم الاقتصاد المجتمع ولم يحل
مشكلات كبيره وظلها بنك اخر في بعض
التلوين والتنويع قامت كذلك شركات تامين
اسلاميه
ولكن عندما عندما اقامه الدوله نفسها
عندما قامت للحركه الاسلاميه دوله ارادت
ان تستفيد من القروض التي تعطيها المؤسسه
الدوليه
المصرفيه مثل البنك الدولي مثل صندوق
النقد مثل بنك التنميه الافريقي كانت تريد
ان تبني سد لانها كانت تفحص كذلك عن
انجازات اقتصاديه سياسيه
انا دائما اقول من اطرف الاوراق التي
قراتها هي اوراق المؤتمر الاقتصادي
الاسلامي لتحليل الفوائد الربويه في
القروض العالميه
احد الفقهاء قال انه لو طلب عليه ان ينقل
جبل اذا كان ايسر له من ان ينظر في هذه
المساله المعقده التي لا يفهمها ولا
يستطيع المواجهتها فهذا هذا الماء الزق
الذي واجهتهم محاولات اسلمت المصارف
اسلمت الاقتصاد مثل الخروج من الحاجه
الملحه الى
الربا
يتحدث عن الاضطرار لكن احنا ما كنا مضطرين
ان نبني سد لكن نحتاج للسد لانه السد
سيساهم مساهمه كبيره جدا في تحولات زراعيه
في السودان يحتاجها
فيضطر ان يستدينوا من المنظمات الدوليه
ويعقد المؤتمر لذلك
ودائما كما ذكرت ان يعود الناس الى نصوص
هذا المؤتمر ويقرا هذه الاوراق ويشاهد هذا
المازق انك انت تدعو الاقتصاد الاسلامي
وتدعو الى قوانين اسلاميه ولكنك لا تفهم
ما هي هذه القوانيس ولا ما هو هذا
الاقتصاد الاسلامي ترفع شعارات لان تضمن
لك تعبئه سياسيه ولكنك لا تستطيع ان تفصل
هذه الشعارات او تنزلها على الواقع طيب
اي مدى الاموال عندما جاء يعني
بالضخ في موضوع مساله الربا والبنوك
العصريه الموجوده بان لا يجوز التعامل
معها والتعامل مع بنوك ان هذه لها لديها
منتجات اسلاميه الى اي مدى لو بايجاز
تعطيني عشان بنتقل لمحور اخر الى اي مدى
كان ساهمت في ضخم ميزانيه
الحركه الاسلاميه في السودان في مطلع
التسعينات
تلقى على البنوك الاسلاميه في السودان لان
هي انها ساهمت في دعم الحركه الاسلاميه
طبعا هي من ناحيه
العناصر العامله اغلبها من الحركه
الاسلاميه كبار الوظائف
مجلس الاداره العلاقات نفسها التي خلقت
هذه المصارف في علاقات الحركه الاسلاميه
فلذلك استفادت منها الحركه الاسلاميه
لكنها في النهايه كانت تعمل في اطار
القانون السوداني وكانت مضطره ان تتعامل
مع طيف من رجال الاعمال مختلفين ولكنها
بالنسبه لي في خاتمه المضاف هي بنك راس
مالي عادي يدعم الراسماليه كما تدعم كل
البنوك الراسماليه وليس فيه من الاسلام
سوى هذا الاسم فهل تذكر لي كم حجم
كميزانيه او حضرتك ذكرت في كتابك عن
الحركه الاسلاميه في السودان فصل عنها
الموضوع هذا هل تذكرني حجم الميزانيه التي
ساهمت وساعدت الحركه الاسلاميه في ذلك
الوقت البنوك الاسلاميه
وطبعا انا كتبت فصله عن الاقتصاد الانقاص
كله
وفي العوده الى الخلفيات انه
الحركه الاسلاميه نفسها كانت حركه موظفين
دخلت قطاع التجاره بعض المصالحه الوطنيه
بعد 77
وعندما دخلت قطاع التجاره هذا القطاع ساهم
لانه هذه الحركه تخوض مثلا انتخابات
فكانت تحتاج للمال وكانت تجد دعم اقليمي
ولا دولي ولذلك ساهمت هذه المؤسسات
الاسلاميه مساهمه كبيره جدا في دعم عملها
الحزبي ولكن عندما تحولت الى دوله كذلك
كانت كل الدوله معها الاقتصاد الانقاص
تحول الى اقتصاد يدعم فئه معينه وليس
اقتصاد سوداني بالمعنى وهذا يحدث في كل
المجالات انه الحركه الاسلاميه نفسها تحول
من حزب مفتوح الى طائفه تخدم لا يعرفون
بعضهم بعضا وتقوم علاقات المعروفه في
السياقات السياسيه الاقتصاديه علاقه القوه
انك في البدايه
[موسيقى]
سنؤسس شركه سويا لاننا اعضاء في هذه
الطائفه ثم
الجيل الثاني من ابنائنا سيتزوجون
وستصبح هذه الفئه التي يحتكر المال تحتكر
السلطه ذكر العلم وهكذا وهذا احدث هذا
الوضع الذي ادى الى سقوط الانقاذ قبل
السؤال الاخير ابغى اسالك استاذ استاذ
محبوب فريق لنا ما بين المطالبه اليوم بين
دستور اسلامي واين او دستور مدني واين تقف
الحركه الاسلاميه من هذا اليوم هو الدستور
لابد ان يكون مدنيا في مجتمع معاصر
المسلمون اليوم هم في سياق عالم معاصر ما
لا يعيشون في كوكب اخر يعيشون مع كل
التجربه الحضاريه مع كل الكسب البشري
عندما كتب الامام محمد عبد الصوره المصري
اشار الى انه
رساله النبي محمد عليه الصلاه والسلام
عندما جاءت كانت البشريه في مستوى من
الرقي بحيث تتقبل هذه الرساله هي ليست
كرساله موسى مثلا فيها المعجزات وفيها
الاحكام القاسيه
البشريه حدث فيها تحول وجودي هذا التحول
الوجود الحضاري ليس فقط بمعنى نهايه
التاريخ ولكن بمعنى انه نعيش في عالم واحد
كان ينبغي ان يكون للمسلمين اسهام فكري في
التطور الدستوري المعاصر لكن واقع الامر
ان التجارب الاسلاميه المتخلفه عن التجارب
الدستوريه المعاصره الاجتهاد الاسلامي في
الاقتصاد او في الفقه او في القانون او في
الدستور هو اجتهاد متخلف دعاه الحركات
الاسلاميه ليسوا بمستوى هذه الاسئله
الصعبه وليس بمستوى هذه التحديات
المراكز البحث العلمي في الجامعات الان
تقوم بتطور هائل في المناهج يعني المناهج
التي خلقت الحضاره المعاصره التي ابدعت
الصاروخ العاب
التلفون
وفجرت شريحه السيليكون هذه نفسها المناهج
التي اللبس العقول التي خلقت المناهج
الانسانيه المعاصره بالقانون او في
الاقتصاد او في الفلسفه او في التربيه
فنحن نحن بعيدين عن هذا التحدي طب استاذ
بختم معك بهذا السؤال شعار الاسلام هو
الحل هل انتهى مفعوله اليوم هل اصبحت
الحركه الاسلاميه تنادي عوضا عنه
الديمقراطيه او العلمانيه هي الحل ام ان
هو مجرد
حيله
زمنيه واقتيه لتجاوز
السقوط بعد الربيع العربي للحركه
الاسلاميه هو هذا الشعار منذ ان طرح كان
شعارا ناقصا وغامضا وسياسيا الاسلام هو
الحل لم يكن الذي طرحه يعلم انه كيف سيكون
الحل في اقتصاد دوله معاصره او كيف
سيقوم بتاسيس دستور لدوله معاصره باعتبارا
الاسلام
هو هو الحل
فالحركات الاسلاميه التي نتحدث عنها هي
حركات نشات قبل 150 عام عندما خرج
الافغاني
وتتلمز عليه محمد عبده ثم تلمز على محمد
عبده رشيد ثم تتلمز على رشيد رضا السيد
البنا فهذه حركات حركات تجديد من القرن
قبل الماضي فهي تاريخيا
بحسب هذا التطور الضخم هذا التسارع الكبير
نحن مررنا باكثر من ثوره في الاتصالات وفي
المناهج هذا كله يقتضي ان هذه الحركات ان
تقوم
بمراجعه جزريه
وبتقديم برنامج مختلف عما كانت عليه وانا
اعتقد انها حتى هذه اللحظه التي نتحدث
فيها يعاجزه عن ذلك طيب موضوع الان الحركه
الاسلاميه او الشخوص في داخل الحركه
الاسلاميه بتبني فكره العلمانيه هي الحل
هل هذا ايمان
يعني حقيقي
انه بمرحله معينه يعني لتخطي ازمه او
نكبات الجماعه او الحركه الاسلاميه
هنالك اجتهادات حقيقيه مثلا كالذي قامت به
النهضه في تونس انما فصلت بين السياسي
والدعوي هذا تطور ضخم جدا في السياقه
الاسلاميه لكن لانه حركه النهضه هي نخبه
في لندن وفي باريس هذه النخوه دارسه تطبيق
العملي السيد محبوب لم يتغير شيء
ما ادري يعني ما استطيع ان اجيب على هذا
السؤال ولكن نظريا هي قامت بتطور كبير جدا
فيما يتعلق بفصل الدعوي من
من السياسي هذا تحول كبير جدا هنا في
السودان كذلك السيده الصادقه المهدي اشار
الى الدوله المدنيه ولكن حركات اسلاميه
دائما لا ترضى ان تندرج في السياقه العام
لانه هذا يحرمها التميز فاثارت اشكال هنا
في على لانه بدل ما استعمال كلمه علمانيه
وكلمه علمانيه كلمه معقده وجاءت في
الصياغه الغربي استعمل كلمه مدنيه كي نحل
هذا الاشكال منذ ما قبل الاستقلال ولكن
اعترضت على كلمه مدنيه في الدستور المجالس
اخيرا يعني فالاشكالات حقيقيه والاشكالات
كبيره وتقتضي عمق وشجاعه هائله حتى واجه
وتبقى ايضا اعاده يعني شعور الثقه
للحركه الاسلاميه ولمن تبنى مثل فكره
الدوله المدنيه لان من التاريخ يعني انهم
كثيرا ما ارتدوا ثيابا
بخلاف قناعاتهم وبخلاف المنهج الحقيقي
يعني فهناك من هو لازال يخشى بان رفع
الشعار
المدنيه هي الحل عوضا عن الاسلام هو الحل
انها مجرد حيله مؤقته سريعا سرعان ما تعود
الامور الى يعني شكلها سابق
انك تقول ان المدنيه هي الحل ولكن ان تجيب
على هذه التجربه التي استمرت 150 عام اين
فشلت واين الخلل وكيف يمكن للمسلم على
العالم والمسلمين ان يتجاوب مع اتجاهات
المعاصره والديمقراطيه في التاريخ
يعطيك الف عافيه الساده وشاكره لك حضورك
معنا ومشاركتنا في هذا الجزئين وتسليط
الضوء على قضيه جدا مهمه حتما ستبقى معنا
لسنوات يعني وسنوات كثيره اسمح لي الله
يسلمك اختي من هنا حلقتنا عن موضوع تطبيق
الشريعه في السودان وقوانين سبتمبر سجل
رائد تجربتي تطبيق الشريعه الاسلاميه
ومنظرها حسن الترابي بعد سنوات من خروجه
من السلطه واعفائه من مناصبه تراجعه عن
تاييد تطبيق احكام القطع والرجل والرده
بالمقابل وثق الناشط الالماني في حقوق
الانسان وصاحب استوديو كوش بام درمان في
البومه ومجموعاته الفوتوغرافيه الخاصه
بعدد من ضحايا قوانين سبتمبر مبتوري
الايدي والاطراف ويظل السؤال هل شعار
الاسلام هو الحل لحركات الاسلام السياسي
الاصوليه مجرد اله للوصول الى الحكم
وللكسب السياسي
حتى وان كانت باطراف صناعيه هذا جماعات
وانا هدى الصالح
[موسيقى]